Peter when we first met you I believe it
was 2014 in the summertime so it's
almost been four years now exactly and
we heard from you and this this
interview is done incredibly well as all
viewers have but this one I'd love to
play it for you if you don't mind
sure okay great great I know this feels
like a Senate hearing but it's not I
don't know I just I didn't do anything
criminal I'm good I remember that about
my lawyer
good okay no this is about we'll keep it
on screenwriting here and we have a
great clip to play so here we go whoops
and though I'm no good at it
the reason that I'm a teacher and a
consultant and a story doctor is that I
my big secret is I don't enjoy writing
screenplays I tried for a while to do it
but it's not my thing
I coach repayed I'd be in the chips
because I'm a poet that's what I love to
write and I also like to write novels
but years ago the reason I became what I
am is I failed to complete a screenplay
it got huge interested and I realized at
the end of it says I don't like this
form it's just not for me
I love analyzing it I love understanding
how it works I love helping other people
do it but I don't enjoy sitting down
every day and writing in the screenplay
form it's not my thing okay
yeah great so that was four years ago
and what I found from from an email from
you is that you've actually completed a
historical TV series yeah and I still
hate writing okay then that comes I'm
always gonna hate it okay I was just
telling Susie yesterday god I hate this
but I'll tell you yes I've had some
success and what's great about that is
is that it's here here's the really
great thing because when you're a
teacher you don't really know for sure
my stuff actually helps it actually
turns out to work good stuff I've been
teaching actually has helped me which is
a huge relief because when you're a
teacher you're often up there and it's
easy to pontificate and say oh do this
and this form try this tool and but most
some of my tools were terrible but
a lot of them actually worked but I
still hate writing and I that's always
probably going to be the case and I
think maybe there are some writers who
don't hate writing who they just love it
and they get ten in the morning and I
can't wait to get to the desk but I'm
always gonna loathe it but it is I guess
I'm good enough at it now to get paid
and so I'll do it it's it's actually fun
to get paid
yeah and it's fun to know that your
stuffs actually gonna be out there but
yeah I mean and I'll tell you something
else I I've been consulting and even
ghost writing and and and story
doctoring and teaching for 20 years and
I quit writing
I quit the whole idea that I was gonna
write like at least six times I just
like screw this and I met it this is
terrible it's awful I'm never gonna
succeed and I stopped I stopped for
several years and I did that several
times because the process of writing is
so excruciating I think for me and for
other people you know I have to say my
my my lovely bride Suzie is a very
successful writer in South Africa and we
can cut this if she doesn't like tell
this story she's very successful in
South Africa as a writer she has a a
column and she's created her own voice I
mean she came here and she started
studying television and oh god she's
frowning at me I probably shouldn't say
this anyway she said my god this is hard
and and and and it is hard so film and
television structure is difficult it's a
difficult form to master it has so many
different components I think if you're a
writer if you're a novelist it's
difficult to all writing is hard but
television and film are are
excruciatingly ly complex there are so
many moving parts to doing that
that I think it may be one of the harder
writing forms and it was certainly the
case for me that that's the case so yes
I I stand by the fact that I hate
writing so what changed I'm sorry to
interrupt but what what changed I guess
I got that I guess I got people that
wanted to pay me to co-write with them
as opposed to just story doctor so I
would and because of that and also I
found the right partner and here this is
critical especially when you're writing
in television and film I know people
that do it alone and they're great I
don't know how that's even possible I
highly recommend that you get a partner
a writing partner I've had a couple in
the last year that have been marvelous
for me and when you find the right
partner it's almost like you've gone
from a singles bar to a couple it's like
oh yeah I love you and yes you're here
you can help it no no and that's really
what it feels like it's like it also
they'll admire you and they tell you're
great and that's something you need
someone to tell you you're great when
you're a writer because you feel like
crap all the time and you're also
getting producers and managers and
agents whose main job is to tell you
your crap that's what they do
this is crap this is pretty much you
just put that on
autoplay when your oh I'm my managers
calling what are they gonna say they're
gonna say this is crap yeah and that's
what they do it this is crap how dare
you I just talked to someone about this
story well they say it's crap Peter it's
absolute crap and I have to say again
that is also what you got to get used to
in the commercial field which is that
and I think William Goldman said this a
long time ago and I didn't realize that
true was he said everything everything
is a piece of he says when they
refer to your script when they've just
may may have bought it for a million
dollars I can hey I just read your piece
of
you know we're filming your piece of
next week right it's a piece of
so anybody who feels like well I'm
gonna be validated
I need to be affirmed and you should not
go into the hollywood writing business
because whatever the culture is that
originated in hollywood and i think it
was a bad deal for writers i think i'm
back in the 30s we gave up our
birthright for a mess of pottage and
when we said hey we don't need our name
on the it's not our movie we're just the
write whatever happened back then
there's a toxic relationship that was
commemorated back then between the
writer and the producer and the
relationship is the producers in charge
the writers sort of servile and and
they're going to get the abuse and
whenever there's a problem it's usually
a problem for the writer it's the Perdue
it's not the producers problem it's the
writers problem you just didn't write it
well enough right so you are gonna get a
lot of criticism and abuse even when
they say they like your thing even when
they buy your thing you're still gonna
be well it's a piece of it's it's
and that's just sort of seems to be at
least in my experience what it's like so
you need a writing partner and grab your
hand left okay darling
yes we're great aren't we yes we are it
doesn't matter what they say yes we're
great and that's what writing partners
can do for you I highly recommend you do
not do this alone so knowing that you'd
rather critique or analyze a story
rather than sit down and write it out oh
hang stop right there okay I don't
anymore because I get paid so much more
for actually writing well how did that
happen I guess because the things I've
been analyzing and thinking about and
teaching for 20 years a lot of them have
turned out to actually work okay
so so it's kind of nice you know I've
been talking about all the BMOC and you
know the structural tool and all the
core woman was stuff but what it turns
out is they these things actually do
help and even though it's helped other
writers and I've been told that for a
long time it's great and a relief that
it they actually work so what I find as
a as a writer as a poster teacher is
these tools work but
so it's a relief to have them so when
I'm stymied or I can't move forward I go
back to my own work I go back to my own
book I go back to my own lectures then I
go okay where am I like I'm working on a
miniseries now about Jack Johnson who
was the first African American
heavyweight champion boxing chapter in
the US and it's it's been sold a
production company and but they want
they want changes on co-writing it with
a brilliant guy that I met actually at a
talk I gave and I often meet people that
I collaborate with well when I give a
talk and he had this project and it was
marvelous but one of the things I talk
about is the superhero a model because
you know superheroes are big now right
whether they're serious like some of the
of the serious stories or if they're if
they're a comic like in Deadpool - we
can talk about that - but the superhero
is huge now and so the superhero model
involves a very particular tool we can
talk about at some point oh if I go into
it now but what I decided was because
several people had taken a pass at Jack
Johnson and I think someone actually
making a movie I'm not very big but and
I don't think I'm giving away anything
here secrets wise a superhero the reason
a superhero is fun to watch is not for
the same reason most he ORS are fun to
watch most heroes are fun to watch
because they're wounded and they've got
some big bleeding wound and and we're
gonna watch them heal it we're gonna
watch that's the story
superheroes know superheroes are not
wounded they're superheroes often the
old-fashioned superhero the in 300 Lee
and Isaac Snyder's 300 leonidas he
doesn't have a wound it's like old my
mommy hurt me and I gotta figure out how
to do that
no in 300 he's an old-fashioned superior
because all the reason we want to watch
an old-fashioned cpu's to see if he can
lift the bigger weight that the villains
putting on him at the four crucial
points of the story the villain just
gets bigger and says hey yeah you could
lift that 300 pounds huh think of the
villain and a superhero as a deranged
trainer at Gold's Gym and and you he's
alright so you're gonna lift 300 pounds
right or you did that okay so at the 30
page point you lifted the 300 pounds
okay 60 page point we're gonna put 900
pounds on there can you lift that so the
superhero secret of a superhero story
that kind of superstore there's several
kinds is that can he lift the bigger
weight the villains put on that rack
that's it it's not about psychology it's
not about core levels so that was our
job with Jack Johnson how can the
villain get bigger on at the end of each
episode what's the bigger weight they
could put on Jack Johnson now instead of
spending weeks and months figuring out
how is he wounded how are we gonna give
him a mentors on one side loners only
other no no it's all about how big is
that villain is that feeling getting
bigger because if the villains getting
bigger the audience is gonna watch
Shakespeare did the same thing by the
way and I used to direct Shakespeare in
New York when I was in after school and
Shakespeare had wrestling matches in
which the villain just got bigger and
bigger so in other words long story
short and not anymore but I really can
use my tools to solve story problems
that I'm getting paid to solve so when
they work I'm so excited I'm so ecstatic
it means all the 20 years I've spent
doing this is actually paying off for me
and also now I have a little bit more
credibility and when I teach right
because the rap on teachers as well you
can teach what you can't do right yeah
that's what you're teaching you're not
doing okay I get it
well now I'm doing so I can say okay
well yeah if these tools actually do
work so shut up
shut up aye aye I did it
nanny Annie I want to hear your process
for when this partner approached you did
you try to talk yourself out of working
with this person oh no I would there's
several but the one guy I love I don't
know if Richard would want me to give
his last now that's okay but Richard I
met Richard finger yeah I'll tell you
who he is he's a great guy he's a Texan
and and he met me what I was speaking in
story expo in LA a couple of years ago
and and and I was giving a lecture on
action heroes and after he says you know
I'd kind of like you to take a look at
this story but he doesn't really talk
that way we run this fellowship and and
I love Jackson I mean what I'd never
heard of Jack Johnson and not only is
Jack Johnson a cool the first
african-american heavyweight champion
he's a real guy he's a superhero I mean
you can't believe what this guy did he
what he tried to race at the Indy 500 he
had his own sports car I mean they
wouldn't let him because he was black
but this guy lived in 1900 and he just
acted like the Ku Klux Klan never
existed he walk went where he wanted he
did what he wanted he loved who he
wanted and he was by the way Muhammad
Ali says he was a better boxer than he
was
Muhammad Ali says that and the one guy
who saw them both box because there's a
guy who found her green magazines really
old one more mkb he taught Jack Johnson
vibes let me so mad he said Jack Johnson
was better and by the way when this guy
was fighting in America the white
audiences were throwing chairs at him
why he was boxing I mean he had to dodge
bottles in the ring and he still became
heavier champion they passed them they
prosecuted him for the man at because he
he liked to marry white girls which at
that time you did not do and so his and
then he went to Leavenworth prison
because they were so angry at him
for what
the violations of what's called the Mann
Act which was Trant is called the white
slavery Act it was if you transported a
woman over state lines it was just BS it
was designed to prosecute whoever the
federal government to prosecute so you
put her in the Leavenworth and then the
warden was so impressed by him that he
ended up giving letting him have
exhibition matches inside Leavenworth
and then he got out and he died in a car
crash in 47
but again just like leonidas in 300 this
guy
the interesting part of his story was
the villains got bigger and bigger right
that were that were on that were
prosecuting him the villains got bigger
and bigger at first it was just the
local folks then it became the state
cops in Chicago then it became the
federal cops all prosecuting Jack
Johnson for who he was
so this fit my superhero for me great
and and Richard kept saying well let's
just do one more he started writing it
and then I said well he was hiring me to
help him which I do I cut do consults
and you can hire me and then I'll I'll
critique your work and he finds a no
Peter I'm paying you so damn much money
to consult with me you just take half
the doggone thing and let's do it
together and that'll save me money and
so that's what we did and Richard and I
just we work so well together we're
working on another project Nero which is
a famous Roman Emperor who's a mass
murderer and kind of an antihero I have
a again III found out and figured how
anti-heroes work have been teaching that
for some time and that tool works great
too by the way so the tools that I'm
using are the tools that I constructed
to teach with and so far they all work
there's a couple tools I have that are
crappy that haven't turned out to work
that well and when I really put them
into practice we can talk about those
too but I'd rather talk about the ones
that do work here just real quickly I
would love to hear what just just real
quickly why was he such a threat to
people and then we'll move on Joe
Johnson well first of all he was this
big beautiful black
man who was completely unscared right he
was and he was had kind of a smirk who's
kind of James Bond had a little
arrogance right he was just a guy who
didn't give a about your anger at
him he didn't care whether or not you
were upset with him for not following
the rules he was a rebel at a time when
if you were a black man and you were
even seen with a white woman you could
get lynched literally get lynched and he
was also a great musician he had a
nightclub act this guy did everything he
was a pop star right he played a viola
and there's film of him doing it so this
guy could do anything he was like jay-z
combined with Muhammad Ali combined with
double-oh-seven
right and and everybody all the white
authority figures hated him and he just
didn't care he did exactly what he
wanted to do so he's an amazing
character and I know we're going to get
somebody amazing to play him so you're
shopping the series around you're
looking for a production company or you
know it's been so disorganized nobody
but we want to sell it to Netflix we
want to sell it to somebody else I want
to be involved in that to a History
Channel because I I know what a
fantastic story this is it sounds like
it and and it's just the kind of story
that is perfect for a time for this time
african-american hero which i think is
is timely
you know I'm a white guy so I am I
understand that my kind of guys pretty
much run Hollywood for a long time I
think it's time that changed but the
story theme here is about contravening
the rules is about new heroes so I think
it's a great chance to show a real guy
you know I mean his real life was so
insanely cool that she really couldn't
make it up so it's a great it's a great
idea and I know it's gonna sell so where
did you go to start shopping it around I
know you said it's already been sold but
can you take a step back there are well
since it's happening right now I can't
take exactly we're going short short but
we're looking at channels we're looking
at channels that have names that have
channel in the name that's also yes and
the big companies I mean look there's 14
billion dollars worth of money now in
the three in the two fields internet
platform and cable there's fourteen
billion dollars worth of money chasing
stories right now and it's funny because
Susie's tell us he says don't say it's
easy it's not easy you know it's so hard
and and and you know you've gotta be
experienced and that's all true this
isn't Hollywood's not like there's not
streets paved with gold all right it's
extremely difficult still to sell
anything in this business and it'd be
silly to say it's not but you know this
is the most exciting time I think in
history for television at least in the
US now I'm going over to South Africa in
a couple of weeks to lecture over there
at the Durban film mark I'm also getting
remarried we're not married having
another ceremony but and what the South
America the South African television
market I think is is is growing the I've
just been working with the guy in Brazil
a big soap opera star down there who
wants to do a serial for Netflix I think
worldwide television is just on fire but
the interesting thing is this miniseries
John Jeff Johnson the miniseries form in
television is probably the closest to a
movie form television offers what do I
mean by that the a miniseries like what
you'll see in the assassination of
Gianni Versace and Trust
these are long movies the television
miniseries are like long movies rather
than TV serials now I just have worked
on and been paid for a crime drama
serial for television which is not a
miniseries we talked about that too but
the miniseries form is like a long movie
why is that because you have wounded
characters who at the end of the
miniseries have healed or they bled out
one or the other but they have an arc
okay
and that miniseries arc is just like a
long movie so with Jack Johnson he a
super hero but he still had a a journey
you so you get a progression in the
story I mean for instance an assassin if
Gianni Versace you've got a wounded guy
Andrew Cunanan was a wounded guys dad
wounded him and and his wound never
healed but he tried to heal it and so
you saw this it was like a like a seven
episode long movie so it had a BMOC
which is we can talk about that too
in it so when I'm writing miniseries if
you're a tell if you're a movie writer
who wants to go into television you
should think about as a transition
writing a miniseries because it'll give
you the opportunity to use all your
movie chops but in a television form
that lets you transition into television
because you need to have a character or
psyche characters who are bleeding at
the beginning who get Mentors
and wound rippers all through it and
then they learn the theme of the show
towards the end and then they either
heal or don't and that's what a
miniseries gives you that a serial
television show doesn't give you in
serial television obviously the wounded
person just keeps bleeding all through
it for 100 episodes but miniseries offer
you the form a lot of the forms of a
movie in a television setting my new
sharp objects
I think debuted on Sunday I didn't watch
it I never heard of it oh okay so it's a
Gillian Flynn and I hope I'm
saying her name correctly all the writer
of gone girl and I guess she wrote this
story from cuz I started just listening
to some interviews before she wrote gone
girl these other stories and it's about
a wounded character and it's a female
and she said she's very wounded and has
issues but she's likable and she thought
that was interesting that for this
character had to be defended that she
was likable because she kind of said
well Walter White does he have to be
likable you know some of these other you
know Tony Soprano does he have to be
likable I would argue they are likable
okay but but sympathetic is actually
more important than likability if you
look at Tony Soprano he's a good example
it's old now but I think it's the most
brilliant television ever made I I think
if you haven't seen Sopranos you should
watch it okay because it's still the
most Burley it's like Shakespeare Tony
Soprano is a murderer he's a horrible
human being and that we love him why we
love him because he's God this deep
wound in him and it comes from his
mother and the entire first season of
The Sopranos is about this horrible
mother and how awful she is to Tony and
even though when he tries to kill her on
the gurney when she's there rolling her
out of the out of the nursing home and
she's going he's trying to literally
trying to get over the pole where our
sympathies are with Tony why well here's
a big secret of the anti-hero which I'll
tell you which I talked about earlier
and I heroes are great guys who turned
bad for sympathetic reasons right for
sympathetic reasons Michael Corleone II
becomes a horrible man
why he's saving his dad he's saving his
family right Tony Soprano is a horrible
guy but we like him why because he wants
to save his family he wants hit the
first season of Tony's paddles we're
seeing if he's the Ducks are leaving his
pawn his kids are leaving the nest right
he's trying to get his mom saved into it
into a home check god I leave me alone
you're a
human being so the great secret Ana hero
is to make the villains and the people
around them worse and less likeable than
the hero themselves so Tony Soprano's
mom is the most miserable horrible human
being ever conceived on television chase
says that he's based on his own mom but
so we love Tony because his mom is just
so awful and we think God poor guy no
wonder he turned into a murdering
psychopath
his mom is awful so that's the critical
thing about making someone sympathetic
and and also likable yes it's important
but to make them sympathetic you simply
make the other people around them worse
Michael Corleone II had to save his dad
nobody else would do it
his brother couldn't do it he had these
terrible villains around him that were
shooting his entire family he had to
save his family and in doing so he
eventually lost his family right just
like Tony Soprano Tony Soprano ends up
killing his nephew ends up killing of
people all around him probably ends up
having was somebody shot in that final
restaurant scene around him but we have
great sympathy for him because we see
his wounds the wounds are everything
wounds are why we love a character and
if when you first start out writing a
story you should show me your hero or
your character's wounds so second they
get on screen the second there on screen
show me the wound that's how you get
somebody to be likable you get the note
your characters not likable what you get
all the time from producer that's how to
make them likable keep on bleeding you
give me an example of just showing
whether it's someone waking up in the
morning and they have back pain oh yeah
I'm saying yes of course
Breaking Bad who's this horrible guy he
wanted something you know killing is his
his brother-in-law we don't mind seeing
died but but he winds up ruining his
family entirely Jessie Everett
when we first see Walter White and who
actually first see him in his underwear
in the desert but when we first see him
at home waking up he's waking up in this
awful little bedroom with a terrible
nightstand from from Ikea he's got this
crappy little exercise he gets up on a
next she's broken after about 10 seconds
and one of those step things and then
the camera pans to the wall and we see
on the wall in 1985 Walter White was in
line for a Nobel Prize in Physics and
then we go back to him and he said and
and and he's he's dead he's been
something's murdered him what is it well
we find out much later what it is that
he was betrayed he was he was a betrayed
by it by his partner by his love but he
is and then he goes and he slumps out
he's sitting at this breakfast table and
it's his 50th birthday and he gets soy
bacon Claire's birthday and that his
wife goes eat it you'll like it and then
his son comes out and says well the
water heaters not working well just you
got to get up early with a person shower
why can't we buy a new water heater
right well cuz Walters a loser right
everything about Walter shows us that
he's been horribly wounded by something
so what we're reading for is from Walter
to get better and so when Walter becomes
a badass I don't know about you but I'm
on his side I know he's killing innocent
people I don't care what her get him get
him
kill that guy so that is a terrible part
of the human soul baby but it's the
device by which we make a character
sympathetic is to show their wounds
because as human beings we're not going
to be interested in good looking perfect
people who have Lincoln making a lot of
money and they're great and everything
they do who gives a we want to see
people that week
identify with because that's not us
we've got problems right I've got
problems right I want to see my problems
and somebody else with problems dealing
with problems okay and you can say well
you know show like like Riverdale
doesn't do that but they do and there's
fantasy shows absolutely fantasy shows
where where that's not the case but most
of the time you do want to see a wound
that's what likability really means oh
they're like me they're screwed up they
don't have it all together wish I did
maybe they'll get it together
right and then that means that I'll get
it together yeah yeah how did they get
it together right but mostly it's just
together like me you know they're not
perfect they're not you know they
they're like me well you've been using
an acronym for a little bit and what's
funny is driving over I was looking over
the notes and I think that David had
said off camera that BMOC stands for big
man on campus and the basketball world
which I was not privy to I did not know
that but if we're writing what what what
is your take beginning middle obstacle
climax that's what that stands for why I
found this out years ago analyzing all
movies that it was equally e mc-squared
moment for me there are four crescendos
in a movie where the hero is asked to
change and asked to learn the theme of
the movie and asked to learn how to heal
all the things I talked about the big
things I talked about healing learning
the theme stopping bleeding all that
there's four times in a movie story
inevitably that that happens at a
crescendo
it's a 30-page of sin 60 pages in 90
pages in and about 108 pages in those I
call the beginning middle obstacle
climax the BMOC
right now that's a structure that is in
every great movie practically you've
ever seen it's not in a Godard movie
okay if you're writing a French Wave
movie I'm sorry I won't be able to help
you that's just a French guy peeing in
an alley for two hours and that's great
right I love those movies but but in a
in a Hollywood film that structure is
invariably in the story and if it's none
there's usually something missing it'll
be superseded someday but that's what's
operating now know that BMOC operates in
everything every movie Dunkirk
in Deadpool everything but now in
Deadpool let's just take an example in
dead poet's a great movie again I'm big
on wounds right what's our wound in the
Deadpool the guy well he's wound because
he's ugly he becomes extremely
disfigured by a chemical bath right and
because of his wound I'm ugly he can't
face his girl
he doesn't feel lovable so the big
crescendos the BMOC points in that movie
or is he gonna have the the balls or the
courage to believe that his his girl
will love him even though he's ugly okay
so we'd he's got to learn in there to
heal his wound does I'm lovable his
wound is I'm not lovable right and and
that's a woman we can all identify with
why a lot of this thing we're not
lovable
so he's his journey in Deadpool the
crescendos of the movie are are you
going to realize you're lovable the
answer for for him is yes no no no yes
yes no no yes because after he gets
chemically doused he he's too ugly and
it takes in most of the movie to get to
where he can take his mask off that's
the climax right that's a final he takes
the mask off
now I used Deadpool I could use a more
highfalutin movie but I want people to
understand these these this pattern the
BMOC works in every movie now you can
say wow that's great Pierre that's a
tool a tie so what the tool will help
you write your movie you got to figure
out what your theme is you got to figure
out what your characters wound is and
you have to forgot how they're gonna be
healing it that's it those are the three
things so the BMOC does that now the
interesting thing is a few years ago I
freaked out and nearly lost my
because I thought okay God movies are
they're gonna be over television is
everything oh my god
I'm a movie god I don't know what to do
so I slowly sort of tentatively said
okay well this work does this work at
one-way meant that works okay that works
this is the BMOC work well the BMOC
turns out to work in television as well
so this tool works in drama and in
comedy and TV as well because why
because what we want to see in a story
is a hero learning to heal and even if
he doesn't heal completely because he
doesn't in TV he's still gonna go on a
journey towards healing a little bit the
critical difference between film and
television this and TV the hero doesn't
heal but he heals a little bit and then
at the end he gets ripped open again so
every week he's gonna heal a little bit
and then get ripped open again every
week 150 times but the BMOC
works at the exact same places in a
television hour than it does in a movie
there's just an extra in because there's
an extra act so let's take a four hour
television
structure the BMOC it's be in MOC the OC
the obstacle point is the point when it
looks like the he was gonna lose and in
a movie this is right at the 90 page
point let's take a movie of writing
those Star Wars Luke gets to the planet
the last rebel planet darth has followed
him there with a homing beacon he's got
a Death Star he's gonna blow up the
whole damn thing there's nothing Luke
can do about it there's just a little
few star fighters and he's got a Death
Star that's it the movies over and then
of course what happens r2d2 says hey I
stole the plans of the Death Star
there's a little hole you can fill it a
missile in if you really get close and
Luke you can the only one get that
missile in that hole if you use the
force not your computer and so the
obstacle point is all is lost and the
climax is Luke learns the theme of the
story Luke will you use the force to
rescue the princess and save the
Republic he puts his computer away all
the other star fighters used if they
couldn't get the missile in he puts his
computer what he's learned he hears oh
we want say Luke
use the force not the computer and he
puts the missile in the hole climax so
the obstacle point is always lost and
the climax is Luke you did it in
Breaking Bad the obstacle point is he's
making meth in the desert Jesse comes
back out with crazy 8 and the other
criminal they're gonna kill him both
Wilson is underwear he has no defense
he's gonna get shot and killed but then
he says teach you I'll teach you how to
cook I'll teach you how to cook my
recipe and they goes really yes and they
go in the RV and Walter throw his poison
into the thing whoosh and the climax is
he kills them both and becomes the mass
murder he's gonna be for the next
hundred and fifty episodes so that's the
climax so the O and the C point and I'm
not explaining this while I'm sorry but
it's in my lecture online it's a complex
little tool but it works so great it's
like a little engine that works any
television structure you want just like
it did in film so what did I learn when
I started learning about television
everything I learned in movies works
every element that I learned about in
movies works in television the
structures just a little more
complicated that's all so you see that
the BMOC
which the B stands for one-time marker
em another Oh another yes 30 page 30 60
90 110 page okay in a script movie
script so to play the devil's advocate
here we sometimes see these comments
usually they come in late at night which
are this is why Hollywood writes
formulaic crap yes how do we how do we
contend that how do we say well then
maybe Hollywood's not for you what what
would be your answer to someone take a
show that I think the new Robert Altman
is a guy named Glover he's a guy that
wrote his writing a short now called
Atlanta now Atlanta is I think the
hippest half-hour show on television
it's a Glover is an african-american
dude he's been an actor in several big
shows and
but now he's got his own show this guy
gives us a world that we've never seen
before which is the world of middle and
lower middle-class african-american
Atlanta
okay now Atlanta is a cool City and it's
a big but there's a big african-american
culture that's part of it lanta I would
submit to you you probably don't know
much about that world right I totally
didn't right he shows you and that's one
of the great things there's nine
questions I ask you when you when I'm
working with you on the television show
one of them is you showing me a world I
ain't seen before because I don't want
to see New York again on the Upper East
Side with please right show me a new
world right so this is the world of
middle and lower middle class Atlanta
and it's very so Africa in American
Atlanta and it's very specific and the
story feels very loose if you go look at
the pilot of Atlanta and it doesn't look
like it's about much sort of like a
Robert Altman movie it's got a very
loose feel to it it feels very
improvisational it feels like there's no
rules at all right and this story it's
got every rule every structure every
storyline every rhythm of How I Met Your
Mother
or the most commercial sitcom II
structure that you've ever won or ever
not want or if a you're a hipster you'd
say I don't want to write that right it
follows all the rules so why is it so
cool because it takes those rules and it
shows you stuff you've never seen the
reason people say I Hollywood so
formulaic is they're looking at bad
unimaginative stories with characters
you've seen a thousand times with
situations you've been in a thousand
times with care with with in a world
you've seen a thousand times set but the
structure the commercial structure is
there because it's beautiful the bones
are beautiful you can take different
bones out put other bones in but there's
an appeal
below the surface of beauty if you look
at what we consider to be beauty if you
took a skeleton you'd see there was a
conformity to the bone structure now you
can put whatever you want on top of that
bone structure you can make the person a
Tunisian you can make them Indian you
can make them American Indian you can
make them whatever you want but the
bones below that determines whether or
not they're beautiful
I think structure of story is like the
bones beneath the the the face it's what
we're instinctively drawn to as human
beings and that doesn't change but what
changes what makes things unique are is
it a new world are these characters we
haven't seen before is this guy have a
wound that we haven't seen before a
Glover in Atlanta gives us a guy who is
a real smart guy who went to Princeton
but he failed because he's got a car one
that he's a loser and he's come back and
he's just bumping around and hanging out
in this middle class lower middle class
world of african-american lanta but he's
a loser he left
Princeton probably because he felt like
I own these people aren't like me which
I felt when I when I went to an Ivy
League school and I felt the same thing
so I cuz I'm a loser I'm gonna drop out
and I'm gonna go back home now back in
Atlanta he gets involved with his cousin
who's a hip hop artist who he shouldn't
get involved with he also already has a
baby
Glover does his character does and he's
not being a really good father but he's
trying he's not being a good husband at
all so all the things all the elements
that we've seen from a dozen sitcoms
from 1960 on are all present in Atlanta
but because we've never seen this world
before because we've never seen this so
he's is kind of a slacker an
african-american slacker and it's also
very funny so every commercial cliche of
structures in this story and yet it's
the freshest thing on television and so
that's my argument against
not using structured think of it this
way in California we have these these a
vanity license plates right and and in a
vanity license plate I think you get
seven letters right and in that seven
letters you've got to be witty okay
you can't go oh man you know what it's
such a cliche to have seven letters my
vanity place kind of 42 because if you
take if you make the vanity about 42
characters long it's not going to be
funny when you say you know if you have
a seven letter word that says let's say
you're driving a Corvette and you're
seven letters are two inches right okay
that's funny yeah seven got me laughs if
it was a 42 letter play you go hey I
Drive a Vette because I have a small
penis is that funny
I know because the form is too big so
commercial form is what we delight and
we want the limitations of commercial
form produce the the entertainment right
the fact it's a half an hour means you
must cram certain things in it and the
delight of an audience in a commercial
art form is how are they going to cram
something we've never heard about and is
witty into this limited commercial form
that's what commercial art does that's
why it's commercial art you want to make
a sitcom that doesn't follow the rules
great make one that's four hours long
don't follow any of the rules you can do
it but it's not commercial art and your
audience will probably be fairly limited
unless you're such a super genius you're
gonna create an entire new art form
that's what Susie's gonna do
she's look you can make an entire new
art form please God let's see it from
you I'd love to see it but you're gonna
have to be greater than Shakespeare who
by the way used a 3 X structure okay
Shakespeare worked inside a commercial
structure the structure of
stratford-on-avon
he worked inside that structure his
plays were inside a commercial structure
they're the greatest place in history so
you can be original and be commercial -
that's my seductive message for for the
Hollywood that there is a
Hollywood pimp telling you come on baby
get in the Sirah glio do it our way
you can still be original we put out a
call a few days ago on our community tab
on YouTube for people to chime in with
some questions so I was gonna read a few
of that's okay oh yes please
so this one comes in from rosemary
orange and rosemary writes when you
write a spec pilot how many episodes
should you have ready to go do you only
pitch the pilot yeah you only purchase a
pilot and like everything I say is
probably wrong I'm just going on my
experience right and because everybody
can be different and everybody there's
no nobody knows how showbiz works but
I'll give you what I think and what's
working for us we for Jack Johnson we
wrote a pilot and four other episodes
but everybody only wants to read the
pilot okay now we have outlines - for
the other four episodes but generally
speaking and it's great to have five
episodes found OC extreme example I
think David Simon's wire he had written
every episode and he put that on a story
by believing these extended out ones but
I think I think what you need generally
speaking and check this with managers
and agents because I don't know
sometimes I mean I'm not a manager
nation but a pilot is is the crucial
thing to have and then a one or two
sheet which gives it the concept of the
show which is you know you say you're
like with Jack Johnson we've got a it's
a it's two pages it's Jack on the cover
and then it's some it's God what's our
cut line
I'm Raging Bull meets somebody but
anyway so it's two-page concept cheap
but the pilot we work and work and work
and work on now
written for other episodes written the
whole miniseries but we haven't what
they seem to want to see is the pilot
this two-page concept line and then also
a Raging Bull meets some rocky that
makes sense right so the pilot is our
pilot is a long tile it's it's
miniseries it's actually a hundred
twenty pages it's probably too long but
yes see the pilot and then have the
other episodes if you've got them done
ready and but the pilot is what
everybody reads and then they're going
to also say you want it then we want a
sails deck when they get to that we're
actually compiling what's called a sails
deck now sails decks are essentially at
least as far as I can tell about 20 or
30 PowerPoint slides or if you're if
you're smart and you have a Mac they're
what they're not a PowerPoint anyway but
they are essentially two or three lines
per deck what this shows about who the
market is who the audience is for
they're generally for the producers
sales team with a sit around sort of
brain-dead up from school what are we
really gonna buy this what is it what's
it about so it it breaks down this
miniseries with what it's about who's it
for who's the audience gonna be that
kind of thing but maybe she just wait to
do the sales tech after you get your
interest from your manager an agent but
basically a pilot
okay the pilots the real critical thing
to have and a concept sheet does this
sales deck have any graphics in it or
yes yeah yeah yeah I mean I'd show you
ours but I don't think I can you know
that's okay it's like 20 20 slides it's
so you know first I'll give me to the
first lady Jack Johnson there he is and
then it's you know
Muhammad Ali meets uh no what did I say
raging raging bowl meets rocky that's a
slide you go to the next slide you know
he was the first great african-american
heavyweight in history he broke all the
rules right each one of these is a slide
so imagine you're a production company
watching song okay this is what we're
gonna buy okay that's really what it is
it's just like a sales deck like card
after card
you know this will break all the rules
you know this will give you the most
money it's a sales technique that's what
a sales deck is and it's designed to
give the production company an idea what
they're buying because they don't want
to read the pilot that way too lazy like
oh okay I would read the pilot project
pages long just give this to Maya my
person that breaks this all down because
I used to be a story analyst a script
reader and this was used to be my job
when someone got interested in the
project they'd go okay well they sent us
the pilot sounds really good I'd rather
to concept agent here Peter you read it
and then let me get into a five-page who
five pages man that's all I can do
that's that's what that's what I did for
for seven years I was a script reader
which is a great way to learn how to
tell a movie and television story
because you breaking it down and you're
analyzed I teach this at UCLA and at my
own school Peter Russell script doctor
calm that's Peter Russell script doctor
calm for all your story needs except you
know film courage too but yeah but I so
I teach a class on how to analyze script
and write what's called coverage so when
we send this thing out to production
companies they'll have their script
reader read the pilot and then they'll
synopsize it into a five page synopsis
and then they'll give comments
afterwards which are what are the Bennet
what are the good points of this story
what are the bad points the story what's
the potential development that's what
they do and so a lot of producers who
are good proofs I've worked for fabulous
geniuses like Brian Grazer
and Les Moonves they will actually then
read the pilot lazy Bruce's will just go
oh okay yeah well the coverage looks
good okay and we got a slot so let's
let's buy it or not so but that's why
it's critical for you as a beginning
writer to write the absolute best script
you can write
it's so hard to break into this business
and there's no rules on how to do it
except I have people ask me Peter so how
do I get an agent how do I get a manager
right that's a question you get asked
all the time and I think the greatest
way to answer that is well why don't you
ask yourself how do I be good okay how
do I be a good writer because if you
become a good writer then you can
probably get an agent or a manager okay
so your product on the page has to be
amazing okay that's how you attract
interest no beginning writer probably is
going to sell a concept you know Jack
Johnson's a great story but we have to
write the script you can't just go hey
Jack Johnson on the go yeah okay that's
great go ahead and write it when you're
a beginner you must write the script you
can't just get an agent based on a pitch
and and there's people that sell access
to producers and managers I'm sure
you've interviewed them they say we're
gonna get you in the room with a great
producer we're going to get you the room
with a great agent yeah getting you in
the room yes but then you're gonna go
here's my script and they're gonna go
okay it's no good next right so getting
you in the room with someone is
important as hell yes I'm not minimizing
that at all and it's very difficult and
a few years ago I used to say well just
shoot out your script go to IMDB Pro and
there'll be emails for all the major
production houses there and they'll be
general emails they'll say not to send
it and send it anyway you know what all
those people are taking their emails off
of IMDB Pro there's no way to even get
to them I mean I I used to work for a
guy who I loved and who loved me a big
Network guy who's now a big guy
somewhere else I wanted it I was like I
haven't talked to this nine years well I
got it I know he wants to talk his
name's not even listed in the I company
like these guys are like
American dictators are y'all yo tinted
windows oh yeah I want to speak to no
one right so even getting ahold of these
people now is insanely hard because I
guess they just get you know badgered
all the time so the best way to do it I
know of is to just be really good really
really good I have an I have an in
because I go speak at places I some I'd
like a know what I'm talking about
and as long as I get people afterwards
come after you see hey yeah you sound
great I'd like to see your stuff I know
that other people don't have that so the
best way I think is to be is to have a
super good script that's rare by the way
99% of the time you will see bad stories
when you read a script as a script
reader I'd say and this is a terrible
statistic but people should know 98% of
the time when you read a script and
these are scripts that have already gone
through the process of a big process of
filtering they're going to not be good
because writing a good script is
insanely hard it's just it's hot way
harder than physics of brain surgery way
harder it's funny that you mentioned
just sort of this this dropping off the
script and thinking that that's like the
magical answer because reading something
about Michael Crichton back in the day
in the 90s and he was living in this
like very unassuming place in Santa
Monica which I'm sure is not unassuming
in price but but he was sort of living
in plain sight as they said you know you
wouldn't think that he'd be there and
because people would just drop off he
wanted to be sort of unknown in the
neighborhood because he didn't want all
these manuscripts just put in his
mailbox which was happening so it's kind
of interesting that this theory of hey
if I just know this person I'd get this
to them we're good
you know yes and I know that's that's a
great thing to have pulsing in your
heart because you need that because
that's the only way you're gonna succeed
but I would say to you you say no Peter
I've done all that all you just can you
just get me to the edge you just get
this to the agent this is it I've got it
and I will say to them I would bet you
half my house that it is not good yet
you know you just
please let me look at it and tell you
because I'll bet you it's not good yet
and and I that's a terrible thing to say
but it's look I've spent 20 years before
my stuff is anywhere near I've got so
much respect for a writer that can sit
down and knock off a great script I've
heard that that's possible there's one
writer he works for American crime now
who apparently just went to a coffee
shop one day and said and he's Akali was
a comic script he wrote a script any
soul he was great
he's like Shakespeare but 99.9% of the
people I know in the business that are
very good very talented they didn't do
it that way they spent years before it
got good it's sort of like saying hey I
think I could do stand-up but I don't
want to go and do all the five years for
it gave me the Comedy Store I'm gonna do
it tonight you know and I know that I'm
so good I've never done it but I know
I'm so good that all that that well no
probably not probably not gonna do that
another question that came in from our
YouTube community tab is from cher Davis
and Cher says is it worth it to submit
to contests when you're a new writer oh
yeah I should have thought of that
earlier
the blacklist thing the Nichols those
are ways to get the attention of agents
and managers in fact that's the gold
standard I would say especially today
maybe even more than a few years ago
when you could just go an item DB Pro
and find emails which you can't anymore
for promotion anyways I would say
winning a contest that's guaranteed to
get you some some looks from agents and
managers absolutely I would highly
recommend you do that okay another
question came in from mr. green do I
need to pursue creative writing in
college to learn how to write a
screenplay
I'm currently a business administration
major yeah anything yeah anything works
anything works just just right buying a
book works get going to class works
learning structure is critical for film
and television
way more than I think novel writing some
writers might disagree with me
structure in television and movies is
something you must learn even if you
hate structure because without it you
will fail there is a commercial form go
outside the commercial form if you want
but understand if you don't know the
commercial structure unless you're an
instinctive genius for structure you you
will not know what television movie
structures especially television
structure because TV structure is way
more complicated than movies and and in
getting more so there's a show now
called sneaky pete and i think it has
ten storylines sneaky pete has ten
Sterling's running almost every week
it's insane I mean it used to be two or
three or four now they've got ten story
lines running in every episode
practically so structure is becoming
more important in television I'm not a
big fan of thinking you got to go to
school to learn how to write even though
I I teach at a pretty prestigious
writing school
III just don't think you gotta but if
that's what helps you do it yeah but yes
it's whatever helps you learn structure
but don't think you're gonna just absorb
it on your own most of the time okay
fair enough
Kenan Anderson writes when writing a
spec show what should the balance be
episode wise between the main story
subplots and fillers it depends on what
you want the story to be about you know
a main storyline is just that it's
everything like it let's take Breaking
Bad everybody knows breaking about main
storyline is always walk gonna be a
badass drug dealer and and that
storyline is the storyline that's going
to carry through all six seven years of
the show now what supports that it's up
to you
he's got two other main story lines is
he going to save his family and is he
gonna die
answer you got 28 beats in an hour
story so your your a story lines gonna
have more beats than the others you know
what a beat is by the way beat is a
conflict it's it's it's two people want
somebody and gets resolved so you got 28
beats in an hour maybe 30 if you want to
be super cool and you gotta get your
it's up to you but your main storyline
obviously takes the most time because
it's the most interesting to us there's
no cut and dried answer to these
questions except that you've got to
stick with in the structural form but
it's totally up to you there look this
isn't like being a CPA or even learning
brain surgery that there's so the rules
are so they're tough rules but then
you're on your own okay
they're tough rules then you're on your
own you I can't tell you how many story
beats to to to to ascribe to your main
storylines you are the only one who can
decide that it's so exciting
it's a turkey within within the
constraints within absolute ironclad
restraints it's a riot in a prison and
you can't get out of the prison so you
know you're gonna be in there with a
nail and board you can do whatever you
want but you can't get out of prison the
great analogy okay so chortle games
rights is a streaming service series
episode written differently than a
traditional network cable TV show
episode if so what are the differences
first of all I commend the person on
their name portal games
hopefully I'm saying it yeah I know that
is the coolest name I've heard in years
if you can stream episodes all together
that's names in question we just been
watching because you tend to binge on
them yeah you'll watch them one after
the other you know what let me be honest
and tell you I don't know because we
binge on shows a lot now and I'm trying
to think of would we not binge because
there's a show called billions that we'd
love to binge oh man
once a week I'm gonna I'm gonna go out
on a limb here because I can and this is
probably one I'm gonna say there's no
difference because you you get caught up
in a story or you don't
I don't see why streaming means it's any
different than a traditional Network
show except okay here's one change you
might want to see people know that's not
true either No chortle there's no I
can't think of a single damn difference
and somebody can contradictory but I
don't think there's any difference No
okay fair enough
Diego our rights in specifically for TV
how does one balance giving a satisfying
season or episode for that matter plot
and closure with complete character arcs
while leaving room for a new season that
might be made well you don't want to
heal the wounds that that's basically it
you take a show like Animal Planet
Animal Kingdom I can't remember now
Kingdom Animal Kingdom which is a great
show about John Wells who's kind of
specializing now in taking foreign shows
and then turning him into American shows
you've got a mate reaaargh the poisonous
matriarch Ellen Barkin and her and her
her kids who she's completely massively
screwing up constantly you know you just
never want to have those kids get better
and they don't what I'm just been killed
and the others are just as poisonous as
they were there just a nest of snakes I
mean the great thing about television is
is that you you you you replace healing
which is what you get in a movie with
surprise okay so characters don't change
in television they surprise with new
often appalling aspects of their
character you didn't know about for
instance let me ask you this you
probably have a someone you've known for
20 years right few people and you get
you know them better and better right
some of them
even mm-hm and as you get to know them
better and better don't you find they're
insanely appalling people yeah the more
you know about it that would be oh my
god yeah oh my god they're even worse
than I thought
yeah so that's television uh-huh it's
like you know it's not like that those
people are gonna heal and you uh see you
later Dave I'm glad you're you don't
know with your mother anymore everything
is great it's like huh my god Dave's
really a peril where you're learning new
things about them no I'm just right
right now yeah he wasn't the person I
then ignored I know yeah you're learning
a new things about them that shock you
their surprise okay for instance in Time
The Sopranos what you talked about
earlier
Janice is getting married to a guy named
Richie
a prio and they're they're discussing
their wedding plans one night and he
gets angry at her and suddenly he slaps
her what you've never ever seen him do
before he's never been violent to her
that's a surprise that Richie suddenly
slaps Janice it's not a change in his
character he's not getting worse he's
not doing way to do in a movie I'm
getting worse because my warns but he's
just being Richie but he's a surprise
then Janice goes to a closet while he's
selling you're eating his dinner put my
dinner on the table
got my dump and she comes out of the
closet and she's got a gun and he goes
come by when he shoots she shoots him
right at the table okay that's a new
surprise from you haven't seen her do
that before right so and is she healing
or did are getting worse no she's just
Janice it's a new revelation of
character right so the way you do it in
television is you keep surprising us
with new aspects of a character someone
reveals something about themselves you
didn't know before
that's what television is so great it's
more like real life than movies right
it's just you and your friends learning
more and more horrible appalling things
about each other
that's you as you go along and they're
not things that are gonna make you go
well they're healing or they get rid of
it so it's just they're just horrible
yeah and so that's the big difference
between movies and television that
surprise replaces healing so mag movies
writes in hi Peter
do you wholeheartedly recommend writing
every day without fail or do you think
it might be better to let ideas come to
you slash marinate and then continue
whatever script you are working on
well the prep pad answer here is you
must write every day and I think that's
probably true but I hate writing every
day and that's probably why I failed for
so long so I tell you probably should
write every day but I understand why you
don't but if you don't you probably fail
I don't know I yes you should write
every day but writing is such a horrible
thing it's so hard to write every day
but yes of course you should write every
day but you know I don't know I mean
look what some of the best people I know
that work in in television they're so
happy they don't have to write every day
but doesn't it make sense you'd have to
write every day it makes sense to me I
mean you're gonna get things done
quicker don't go by me I didn't succeed
for a long time I think it's probably
because I was lazy so I think you should
write every day yes
please write every day eat your
vegetables call your mother
call your mother go to therapy get your
oil changed every 5,000 kilometers oh
yeah you can wait a little longer yes
all those things yes well why do you
hate writing every day well because
writing is so hard
first of all you're alone that's that's
why it's good to have a partner it's
just so hard I I don't think maybe some
writers love it I think writing is just
extremely hard and then what are you
gonna write about you get something
you're right about and it's probably
gonna be stuff you already did that
you've got notes on so I just look
writing is just for me and agony I mean
I'm probably a bad person to us what
your habits should be I have terrible
habits and they haven't stood me in good
stead I am NOT a good moral teacher in
any way about
but wouldn't it make sense that it would
be the healthy thing to write every day
and if you can't enjoy it you certainly
should okay you should you should you
should enjoy writing you should always
enjoy what you do
so Alberto writes in can a main
character have two desires sure but
usually only one wound people often
think that they can where they get
excited about the whole idea of a core
wound which they should because it
really gives you an original character
but when we in real life by the way we
have a dozen wounds right I mean you
know let's talk about mine or not but
everybody has more than one wound but
movies and to some extent television
alia more lead or simple okay so you
want to sort of see one big wound but
then yes many simple desires come out of
that you know Tony Soprano had one big
one my mommy hates me so but a bunch of
desires came out of that you know I love
prostitutes love working a strip club
I love hurting people I love to be
violent you know I love to run things I
love being a boss you know I love being
a dad I like so so you can have many
desires just know that all the desires
come out of the wound and they're often
unhealthy okay
they're often unhealthy desires that's
what you want to see if they were
healthy there'd be no show so especially
in television you get wounded then you
do a lot of unhealthy things and
sometimes your superpower and in
television that's another thing you need
to know usually in television your hero
has a superpower and usually that
superpower especially at the beginning
is being used for wrong reasons bad
purposes for instance Don Draper and
madmen has a superpower he's insanely
seductive okay he any seductive as a
womanizer any seductive as an ad man but
it comes from the fact that his mommy
didn't love him right he feels unlovable
so all the things he does he uses his
super power for bad reasons because he's
wounded he seduces women right he he
does ad campaigns for cigarettes and
horrible things
and he's a moral as an ad man because
he's misusing the super power but the
super power came from his wound if he
hadn't been wounded I'm not lovable he
would have never become a great seducer
he wouldn't have needed to so the the
superpower is related to the wound but
the disease but that but the the things
he wants come out of the unhealthy
desires of him trying to make the wound
go away trying to feel better about the
wound every desire is an ability is an
attempt to suppose the the wound to to
to palliate this is from tjw when
writing a TV spec how far in the future
should you know your story multiple
seasons yeah I would say so I'd say you
should know what the end of its gonna be
you really should
what's interesting is you take a show
like Mad Men but you know that the be
the end of the show nothing's really
going to be any different the beginning
there really isn't if the first episode
of Mad Men Don Draper is a New York ad
man who's really unhappy in his marriage
and he's he's got a big hole in his soul
what's the last final scene of of Don
Draper this madman episode he's gonna go
back and be in New York admin he's a
seducer of women untroubled with his
relationship with women and he's got a
big hole in his soul right
so it's not hard to know the ending of
your TV show because it's gonna be the
same as your beginning there's there's
really no unless it's a miniseries where
like true detective we're in season 1
where rusty and Marty actually change
incredibly because that's a movie
basically remember miniseries are long
movies you're always just going to be in
the same place so yeah knowing the
endings not hard
you're gonna be in exactly the same
place as you were at the beginning Buffy
the Vampire Slayer is still slaying
vampires and still not happy about
at the end okay Glover in Atlanta his
character however long Atlanta goes
unless he just wants to say screw you
I'm not going to do what you expect me
to his characters still gonna be bumping
along feeling like the loser at the very
end of Atlanta sneaky pete same thing
sneaky Pete's still gonna be conflicted
about having a family versus being a con
artist being alone versus being with his
family I don't care how many seasons
you'd have so it's not hard figuring out
where your television show is going to
go because it's going nowhere
so our pith rites do you think three-act
structure is mandatory
can you provide an example of a movie
without a three-act structure a movie
without yeah Godard movie yeah any movie
where there's a French kind of array
peeing in an alley
they have no structure but they have no
acts yes any one of those yeah yeah but
you know what's funny John Waters the
flood painful me it was we always
actually do you have a structure it's
very hard to get away from structure
yeah the French movies sometimes do it
I'd love to hear him tell me what
American movie doesn't have that
structure uh maybe what was the movie
with Ethan Hawke where he was shot over
12 years nothing has that doesn't seem
structure to though not boyhood but is
it boy oh okay okay it's got the same
track structure easy get me a good
father
same thing gotta be him up see very hard
to get away with that win commercial
television or movies but I invite people
to try and be super geniuses who break
all the rules
as someone by the name of shaggy Rogers
writes in if you don't mind what pilots
have you sold recently well there's two
that I have sold the production
companies this year okay
one is a serial drama crime serial drama
let me do the logline it's it's true
detective meets ray Donovan and it is a
very very dark story about a guy in
Santa Monica we sat in Santa Monica
because it's Santa Monica is a very
corrupt town was ever talked about it's
old drug money oh really
oh yes and but he's a very dark hero and
he he he solves crimes but he does so
while well he actually saw him because
he's also he has the instincts of a
child molester and he's actually
kidnapped and keeps captive an 11 year
old girl in his basement
yes very dark yeah okay yeah so but he
doesn't molest her but and in fact she
becomes his ally Oh like the Stockholm
Syndrome kind of yes except for both of
them so he's battling this terrible
impulse inside of himself but because
he's battling it because he doesn't give
in to it
he actually develops a relationship with
her and it helps him solve crimes and
she becomes someone who helps himself
crimes and who helps him heal so it's
very dark but it's it has its it's a
crime drama so there is there's it's an
episode and there's a there's a there's
a crime solved every a week but there's
also a long arc over the course of the
entire season and that's sort of
fashionable now to have both to have but
it's a discomfiting premise it's it's
very raw and very dark
and and yeah it's it's um it's it's it's
a it's a dark dark crime drama and the
other one is the Jack Johnson miniseries
which is a miniseries so what I was
thinking to talk about today a little
bit was the fact that I've got this
superhero miniseries then I've also got
this serial drama where the guy doesn't
really heal in that crime drama he
doesn't really heal so his wound is
bleeding all through the season and will
continue to bleed all through the other
seasons he will never get healthy he
will never stop desiring underage girls
but it is a it's like a nuclear activist
contained fire but the struggle is
always there and how do you make him by
the way likable and sympathetic that was
the big question right because that's a
tough one right how do you make that
character like I'm unsympathetic what
about it like in Lolita well that's a
movie and I didn't particularly like
Humbert Humbert but I felt sympathy for
him because he was so he it was so
clearly he was gonna crash and burn
right I mean he was so in in thrall to
this awful awful desire he if he if he
could have heeded given it up yeah who
would want to be in thrall to this awful
desire right so that if you had sympathy
for Humbert Humbert it was that he's
he's doing something that he's gonna
earn him the opprobrium of everyone in
the world and yet he can't not do it
right he can't not do it
so it's like a goats watching a guy who
can't keep himself from cutting his own
throat he's gonna he's gonna do it even
though he knows it's gonna kill him
that's one of the things in this sharp
objects is that she's a cutter and and
yes yes and so so our sympathy for her
is that it's it's wounding behavior that
you can't help
and we see her pain and so I'm showing
and we're showing in this story because
I have a really brilliant co-writer in
this story as well I like working with
other people Lori Johnson is is her name
that help humanize this this guy this
this horrible guy by showing that he was
the victim of an insane horrible father
and that he not only has a genetic
propensity which he has to be to have
this this twisted sexuality but he also
his his own sister was raped and killed
by his father and he had to watch it and
and and and watch all of that happen so
we get that story and he's also suicidal
so we get all that story in in the pilot
which is important when you have someone
this awful you've got to make quickly
show something that makes them more
sympathetic or you've lost your audience
entirely and maybe you should I mean I
know people think Hollywood is horrible
for even entertaining the idea that that
a character oculist should be
sympathetic right so that's part of the
controversy too should you even have a
character audience on the air hmm I
don't know but it's it's a powerful
story so that's those are the two I'm
most involved with right now but I'm
always open for more you know I love
collaborating with people it's my thing
and I always want to go and teach or
talk somewhere I often get somebody to
come with me again and what do you think
of this story and a lot of the times I
say yeah let's do it
um I'm excited to put my learning to use
with somebody else and their vision it
seems to be kind of the way I work the
best okay hiding behind someone else and
then if it's not good hey it's their
fault I did the best I could
that sounds like a good plan yeah it's
gravy this question came in from tornado
boy and he writes maybe some more tips
on writing anti-heroes oh yeah well the
biggest tip is surround them with people
that are worse than them and surround
them with people that push them to being
antihero
so that you feel sympathy for the
antihero that's really the critical key
and again an antihero like like Walter
White and Breaking Bad the reason that
we root for him is the people around him
are worse than him even his his his his
brother-in-law Hank is just horrible
from the beginning we see the way he
bullies Walter and we just can't wait to
see him get his butt kicked it takes a
few years but he's actually getting his
butt kicked all along because he's never
he never learns about Walter and by the
way Hanks a good guy in a lot of ways
he's he's a good uncle he's he's a
provider but because he's so bullying to
Walter because he's such a blowhard he
and he's just one in a constellation of
figures around Walter that we find to be
worse than Walter out Walter obviously
the criminals are worse obviously when
he's dealing with his his work situation
his ex-wife who screwed him out of his
company so everybody around Walter
it makes us wanna root for Walter that's
the critical key for an antihero
thinking about the clothing store scene
oh yeah you know for instance when he's
with his kid right and his kids getting
on jeans and and and these guys are
making fun go to these big boy pens
so these horrible always who are making
fun of a kid with a disability we want
to see their butts kick
and here comes Walter and it's one of
the great and by it is by the way it's
the point of act 3 I have that be FML
see and the and the B mmm was C for
Walter is easy gonna take care of his
family that's one of his questions right
so when those guys bully his kid here's
the climax of that act
Walter comes back in says take a shot
come on come on fight me and we are
cheering Walter because those guys just
crumpled and they're big guys too and
Walters this little wimpy guy even his
wife's a little turned on right because
I look at you right so Walt is standing
up to awful behavior so an antihero and
even though Walter becomes one of the
worst people around even at the end I am
always there Walter machine-gunned all
those guys so make the people around
your antihero just horrible people and
you'll be great you'll love the antihero
this question comes in from Stein call
Ovid
forgive me for saying the name
incorrectly I've sometimes wondered
whether I should write TV series in
addition to features but so far it seems
to me that stories that the stories I
want to tell are better told through
films can mr. Russell give an example of
why a story would be better told as a TV
series well if you love movies and so
many people do and I know that a lot of
people who grew up loving movies they're
kind of appalled that television is
taken over think of it this way you can
tell any movie as a TV miniseries you
can take the movie that you've been
writing for the last four or five years
and you can turn it into a television
miniseries more easily than you can turn
it into a TV series so think of it that
way now I spent several years learning
genres of movies mystery thriller crime
thriller horror all of these genres I
sort of mastered the understanding the
deep understanding of each one of those
genres and every one of those genres is
very different and they all have these
cool tools that I learned to help movie
people
well guess what
turns out when I turn my attention to
television all the rules of movie
thrillers apply to the crime drama that
I'm selling as a serial right now ray
Donovan meets true detective all of
those cool structural tools that work in
seven that work in all these classic
movies turns out those secrets transfer
right over to television so just you
know that everything you've learned
about movies works in TV but the easiest
transition is to move take your movie
idea and turn it into a miniseries why
well for some of the reasons we talked
about earlier which is mainly many
series are like long movies because the
characters have an arc they start with a
wound and they eventually heal or not so
if you're writing movies and you love
movies make the transition to television
by writing a miniseries where you can
simply stretch your idea into a longer
form forget the structure so much but
those cool tools which by the way I have
on my website Peter Russell script
doctor calm I go each genre of movies
has a set of hidden structures and tools
in it just take those in structures and
tools and apply them to your television
show in the same genre writing a comedy
apply the movie comedic rules to your
sitcom writing a romantic comedy same
thing love story same thing adventure
romance same thing write a miniseries
it's a bridge form it'll help you learn
why television has two big differences
with movies one is that the characters
don't really change in television and
the other one is you can tell more than
you can in a movie where you want to
show everything so there's just more
dialogue but those are the two big
differences everything else can be the
same especially in a miniseries it's a
great bridge
for you to learn this new structure and
you'll just have a better chance of
getting your story bought I didn't say
great chance I said better chance
because I think we're up to five hundred
and fifty scripted television shows now
in the u.s. there are a few years ago
there were 200 so and I I believe that's
gonna simply continue I think in 10
years television is going to be five
times as big as it is right now so if
you want your work to sell learn the new
forms by bridging your way to TV through
using your movie as a miniseries
we're miniseries in fashion so to speak
previously and I think we're the
seventies I know there were big
miniseries in the 70s like The Thorn
Birds
there was another show called Shogun so
these were these were big event
television so they'd be on one night for
three or four nights five nights
sometimes but then there was a long
period when they weren't fashionable but
they've gotten very fashionable again
you know Ryan Murphy all these guys who
write these fantastic shows you know the
OJ Simpson trial the trust which is a
great when the Danny Boyle just did
about the Getty family brilliant
miniseries and the assassination of
Gianni Versace they are I think where a
lot of movie makers are going in
television because it's a more
commodious form it's the easiest a way
to transition from film to television so
yeah and I think the miniseries also is
kind of satisfies our desire for seeing
a movie which is I want to see somebody
change I want to see a complete story
right when you're watching Animal
Kingdom
okay well Ellen barkins still going to
be a poisonous okay well let's
have some popcorn at some point you
I sort of see what's gonna happen right
can can we have some resolution
can we actually resolve something in our
lives that's what great movies have
always done for us so I think that
instinct to be have a complete story is
why miniseries have become so much more
popular they're sort of replacing what
movies used to give us which is that
sense of a complete story
ah we're done Ellen barkins dead yay
two of the kids got help they've got
therapy right thank God we can have
dinner now right as opposed to oh god
she's still in jail is she's feeling
tormented right she's still wearing
those awful black contacts yes she is
she still looks like death right in a
movie she would have moved on you'd
probably be dead or she'd be okay but
yeah that's why miniseries they think
they're so popular so you said in the
70s they were popular can you see any
parallels between now and that time do
you think there's there's something in
audiences that is yeah III think that um
we are we love long-form entertainment
and we like that's I think why we binge
series - I think entertainment is
becoming like the Russian novel why
don't we mean right out of the 19th
century us it's not so pretentious but
the Russian novel Tolstoy
got longer longer and bigger and bigger
and bigger bigger right in the night and
I till there were a thousand pages 1500
pages right that's the sign of the
maturity of an art form right that's
when art form gets its best when it gets
big when it gets long I think we're in
in that kind of Suzy hates me saying a
golden age but I think we are in a
golden age of entertainment because the
stories are getting so much longer and
look you can tell everybody is neither a
good guy in ER a bad guy everybody's got
a combination of traits in them right so
a movie can't really show you that
there's not enough time you're either
good or you're bad television and the
longer form can show both the good and
the bad inside of all of us it's a more
sophisticated model of human behavior I
think we're just getting to be more
sophisticated as people to know that
people
stories are complex I'm not all good I'm
not all evil I'm mostly evil but there's
some good in me but that's the mix and
so longer form art can give us a
complete picture of what humanity's
about questions one should ask
themselves about writing a TV show
okay there's nine questions I always ask
when I'm first talking to someone at
their TV show first of all what Stevie
do gives us a great world we need a
great world because we're going to be in
it for 150 episodes right so what's a
great world right I would do an exercise
where I say to you you give me a great
world and don't tell me it's New York
City I want to know ya specific
neighborhood of New York City what's the
great world because great television is
always about a great world now if you
want to talk about New York that give me
a specific world and like there's a show
called billions and this show is
brilliantly written it's probably the
best television out there right now and
it's all about billionaires how they
make their money and how they live their
fascinating lives right another
fascinating world the assassination of
Gianni Versace that was a world of
Versace fashion world in Miami and then
this guy who became a serial killer his
world and never seen it before so carbon
black is this really cool sci-fi show
it's about a cool to the future where
people can change bodies right so they
have sleeves they call it so your world
you want to ask yourself what is the
world of your show Atlanta is probably
the coolest show on television right now
and it's all about this african-american
milieu of middle class lower middle
class Atlanta and this sort of slacker
guy in it and how he's gonna survive in
this slacker world never seen it before
stranger things that's the world of the
80s and that's big nostalgia for kids
that are 20 or 30 right now it people on
their bikes without helmets the
television sets that were tubes with
rabbit ears so the world there is
absolutely about that a style
yeah so big question what's your world
that's what we want to see fantasy
continues to be big I hate it but zombie
is a world that just continues to be
true Tru Blood
vampires romance continues to be good
black comedy world of shameless
white-trash
so worlds are extraordinarily important
in your show
the next question I ask is do you have a
do you have a theme that matters what do
you want to say about the world in your
television show for instance a show like
a Sons of Anarchy which is a great world
the world of motorcycle show the theme
is if you have a bad mom or dad you're
going to be screwed you need to have a
good parent you need to be mentored well
he's not and that means the entire show
is about how the hero of the show fails
because he doesn't have a good mom and
dad his dad's dead his mom's horrible
and and so this truth about life is
often what hipsters ignore when they're
writing a story like I want to write
this story I call it the Whedon speed
it's gonna be a sort of motorcycles and
violence and razor blades and people
smokings crack and rap and I'm like okay
great
ten minutes I love it then what's the
truth about life you're saying sons of
anarchy Kurt Sutter's brilliant writer
why because he's got a theme that this
harrow hero who drives a motorcycle
who's tough who does all the things that
you're saying you want to see the
violence the sex the motorcycles all
that stuff but every episode is about
this guy struggling with the fact he
doesn't have a dad what how do I live my
life without a dad or a mom and he never
figures it out and he's screwed because
it was so theme answers the question in
orange is the new black which is a
brilliant show what's the theme will you
better know yourself Piper can't doesn't
know if she likes girls or boys and the
whole show is about hood or like guys
don't like girls I don't know Who am I
no you tell me who I am so that's a
great theme - so Downton Abbey has a
theme which is that the lower-class is
rising and we have to understand how
it's rising that's the theme of every
episode of Downton Abbey okay so theme
is in struggle in the wire which is
probably the most the intellectuals a
wet dream of a show The Wire David Simon
in his story Bible and that's something
you should also have when you're
pitching a story his message is this
this story I must read this because this
is in the front page of the story Bible
this story is about the human condition
about it's not just a police show it's a
show about how we have taken the urban
underclass and have jailed them and
tormented them and torn them apart in
our stupid drug war okay that's his
theme and it's a social theme and that
motivates every every one of those
episodes so if you don't have that and
it works even in a sitcom you're not
gonna have a show that works so what are
you passionate what do you believe in I
asked my students is sometimes what do
you believe in like I don't know I mean
that's not important I'm gonna write a
hip story no you're not you're gonna
bore us the next question is why do we
want to watch the show every week okay
every week we got to watch a show 100
episodes so you need a great question
right and Breaking Bad what's the great
hook question every week how Bad's
whilst you're gonna break what's he
gonna do this week oh god he's gonna be
even worse okay making a murderer
hey did did he do it or not that's
pretty good question now every week we
get that orange is a new black
it's probably ever gonna figure out if
statics girls are boys no she's not
gonna so but this question continues
it's the hook it's the great question of
the show mr. robot can Elliot take down
the big corporation okay Game of Thrones
which family is gonna win every episode
is about that right and what's the theme
of Game of Thrones by the way it's kind
of important the theme is do you have to
evil to be a great leader okay that's
the whole question for every episode
right so that's an important question
okay so the next one is genre let's not
go into that because I teach that it's a
structural thing but you need to stick
in your genre what parents are your show
like in television if you're gonna write
a TV show you got to ask yourself what
are the parents of the show who watch
shows are like this that you've seen
before him and my hip students I was
gonna have here I don't want ever my
shows like nothing else ever on it's
like okay well then it's not gonna go
it's not going to get on even if you
want it to be completely different from
everything we need to understand what
you're reacting to what did you hate
okay you gotta have parents for the show
and it'll help you build your show if
you do okay so then the next question
and this is super important is how do I
say it what is the question that
torments the hero forever that will
never be resolved
what's the unsolvable dilemma for the
hero that will never ever be solved and
that is in Mad Men it's I am unlovable
and the things I do to make myself
lovable make me so uncomfortable that I
run away Don Draper seduces woman after
woman after woman in that man but every
time they fall in love with him they
always do he runs away because he hasn't
soft his basic dilemma which is I'm
unlovable okay so that is the unsolvable
dilemma
okay even in Buffy the Vampire Slayer
it's I just want to be alpha and
be in high school and be popular no
you're a vampire I don't want to be a
vampire so 150 episodes of that
unsolvable dilemma
okay Bratz Breaking Bad Walt's dying
he's gotta take care of his family
how does he do it he's becomes a drug
dealer and destroys his family so the
thing that makes him want to take care
of his family the way he does it
destroys his family okay
true detective rust versus rust knows
the world is meaningless Marty believes
there's a lot of meaning in the world
how do they resolve that well they do in
the end because remember it's a
miniseries it's like a movie suddenly
and they do both believe the world's a
great place but that's not classic TV
okay so will Walt protect his family to
destroy it will rust you how can good
prevail in a world that's run by the
strongest that's game of Thrones
how can we have a world where there's a
good leader when it's the worst people
who always win right unsolvable dilemma
maybe in the end you know the two people
with the IKEA rugs on their back they're
going to learn but but for the whole
seven eight years they don't have it so
what is the irreconcilable conflict in
your show what is the dilemma that will
never be resolved that that that will
keep people coming back
and obviously that has to do with their
core wound so the next question is
what's the big core wound in your hero
how does that work in your television
show and there's many different ones and
and and it's always about that
unreconciled Lemmon madman I'm unlovable
at airing in Game of Thrones I'm
unlovable everything he does is because
of that Walter's is I'm weak and my
father used to say never corner a weak
man Daniel
they'll turn out to be really strong
weight and Deadpool by their because
this is true also and movies is on ugly
a Randall in this is us which is a great
cereal show even talking much but
Randall is I'm not part of this family
right my skin colors in ermine not
really part of mine Pete and Sneaky Pete
I'm not part of a family great Carl or
Jessica Jones and Jessica Jones I'm not
safe this villain can get me he'll
always get me so core wounds are the
nuclear reactors of your show they
really are and they have to have
Daenerys as core wound in game of
thrones'
powerless and we see the entire first
season for Daenerys she starts out as
this little sex slave for her brother
she's given to this warrior as a sex
object by the end of the season she's
walked through fire and hatched dragon
eggs
so her powerlessness is beginning to go
away but it will continue through the
entire run of Game of Thrones I'm
powerless is she getting powerful she's
beginning to but that'll take a long
time so these are just the beginnings of
the questions that I would ask there's
many others but this is a start when
you're writing television and they are
different from film but those those
start when I would start talking to
someone about their TV show these are
the questions I would ask them at the
beginning issues that were facing
the family at that time like eight is
enough when I would watch it
that wasn't a representation of how I
lived or I didn't have siblings and
things like that
but I watched it as wow that's what
quote the normal families dealt with
right and I could watch it as this
little girl thinking oh I want to be one
of the good you know think about this
they get this seventh heaven and The
Cosby Show
we're both run by rapists so you you
have to ask yourself what were we
watching them
we were watching myths okay we were
watching at a time when I think the
family was actually breaking up and was
dissolute we were watching guys who
literally were in their own personal
lives allegedly committing sex crimes so
what does that tell us about what that
period of time was for television it was
a time when I think we had a much less
sophisticated view of what art could be
television then was I think a propaganda
for a particular way of life that was
mostly BS yes I think well we could go
back farther father knows best
- beaver things like that it was at the
Donna Reed show right yeah yeah so so
that's even more safe within this little
box you know I mean I Love Lucy was
silly and and fun and you could have fun
with them but I'm talking about where
you saw very defined roles for the
mother and father and the road children
versus the Eddie Haskell's
mm-hmm you know and now it's almost as
if okay we know that a lot of stuff's
been a big lie and a lot of the mighty
have fallen in some ways let's just let
it be and kind of revel in that I think
art always does that
you know Leave It to Beaver was
considered a groundbreaking show when it
came out a very realistic show because
it had kids talking back to their
parents Eddie Haskell actually said some
mean things on camera it was a
groundbreaking show at the time it came
out it wasn't compared to say Donna Reed
or the others that were very sanitized
so I think an art form if it's growing
continues to show you and this is really
pompous I'm sorry but I think that's why
television is great now it shows you
better and better what the world's
really like okay so television that I
think is is better because it's more
sophisticated and actually shows us more
of the world than TV did 30 years ago
you know movies were cool because they
showed us stuff TV couldn't movies were
cool in the 70s because we could see
nudity
we could see violence we could see
obscenity we could see adult themes that
TV just couldn't tackle right movies
lost its edge over TV because now we can
see all those things on TV right that's
part of white TV school those rules
don't exist anymore and I think when an
artform is that it's freest it can also
be at its best when it's able to show
everything about a society now we're not
there yet there's still things we can't
show on TV I've got I'm working on a
drunk crime drama right now it's very
controversial it's got a guy in it who
could be a child molester and he's
supposed to be the anti he
the show that's very very controversial
I don't know if it's going to succeed
but I hope it does because when you
can't talk about something you can't
face it and when you can't face it you
can't heal it and so I'm not a big fan
of political correctness and I really
believe television is that it's best
when it doesn't have anybody saying oh
you can't do that no no you can't say
that no no no that's that's beyond
bounds and I think sometimes we have
political correctness from both left and
right that are keeping our artforms from
being free and you can say all you want
about Hollywood being a horrible place
full of awful people and it is
there's tons of terrible people my dad
was a Southern Baptist minister he used
to rail against Hollywood yeah and I
just tell him dad you know what you're
absolutely right I've been out there
it's absolutely full of horrible evil
people you were totally right talking
the pulpit yeah man I couldn't put it
any better but as Milton said and
aeroponics Ivica you can't praise a
cloistered virtue you can't say Oh
Hollywood sucks we've got to shut it
down they've done that in so many
countries in the world they don't have
vibrant TV industries why is our
entertainment industry why do we sell
all over the world it's not because
people love us they hate America you
know they think America is awful why
does America sell all over the world I
think it's because Hollywood for all its
faults doesn't get its money from
government doesn't have a bunch of
puritanical judges saying this you can
say this you can't say this it gets its
power from people paying money to see
its product no rules no regulation it's
the honestly it's it's the most free
market product produced by these
warm-hearted socialists at the top of
every economic entertainment company
they're the most cutthroat
on earth that's what I love Hollywood is
it's anarchy at its best it has no rules
it's funny that you mentioned and I was
in a restaurant after some sort of
scandalous thing broke I won't go into
what it was but I was in between going
somewhere else and I was reading some
notes from a screener that I just saw a
film and so the woman behind me was with
a man and they were both it seemed like
in the same line of work neither
attorneys or social workers and she's
complaining about her day and he's not
listening and I can feel it behind me
and I can feel her frustration and so
then she kind of turned to me and said
well you know I used to work in film and
television and I effing hated it and I
couldn't I was like you know I think
it's time for me to go now but I could
feel the the and it had it was right
after a scandal that broke and it was in
the news and it was on Twitter and
everybody was giving their opinion and
and it was interesting because I didn't
I wasn't even aware that that's how it's
perceived there's so many people I know
who quit working in show business
because they say it's such a poisonous
environment there's so many abusive
people and there are I don't know how
many healthy people work in Hollywood
probably very few everyone in it is
damaged terribly damaged but I think
that was - in Shakespeare's age - look
you know the theatre was banned by the
Puritans as a place of unhealthiness
we're unhealthy things happen I think
where you have no rules you have
societies gangsters move in right but I
think that's where most great art
happens and I also think that nobody
really knows how show business works so
part of the reason I think you guys do
the work you do is so good is missing
you know how does Hollywood work where
the rules I want somebody to give me the
way things work and what I think you
have to say to people is it - guess what
there aren't any rules in this field
this is shadow town this is where you
have to make up your own rules nothing's
going to be given to you there's no
school you can go to little tip on go
here you go there's your showbiz degree
now you can go get a job here's the fee
here's the desk here's your office after
20 years you get a pension no this is
for chancers this industry is for
unhealthy people who are deeply damaged
and hurt by life and they want to create
story for a variety of terrible reasons
but I think out of that comes the
greatest art I think it's always been
that way
I don't know which French guy said it
but he said art is a sewer and from the
sewer emerges gold and I think that's
Hollywood it's never gonna be a place of
healthy people doing things and and I
don't know that you should get in it if
your goal is to lead a healthy
productive life with predictable
outcomes where at the end of your life
you're gonna want great I've got my
pension I'm gonna retire now I'm gonna
go to Florida everything's great I've
got my health insurance and it's why is
that this town is not for you and I I
think that's just always going to be the
way it is Art's dangerous and scary and
it's made by dangerous and scary people